[Music]
[Applause]
broadband users in Ireland are
increasingly getting access to a unique
100% fiber to the building network as a
result of a joint venture between ESB
and Vodafone the joint venture company
delivering this exciting project is Cyro
and we're joined today by its CEO Sean
Atkinson Sean before we go any further
tell us how the project is going well
since 2015 when we kicked off and we've
made great progress our initial
announcement was to do 50 towns and to
do about half a million homes and today
we're working in over 35 of those towns
and we'd be passing 150,000 homes and
this month and so we've made fantastic
progress seven contractors working
across it so I think when with 2015 we
were talking about it was just a started
a start up an idea 120 people working in
the business we're coming off a long way
in a relatively short period of time and
so the progress has been really really
good brought on a number of retailers on
so we've now had a think nine retailers
working for the we're working for us
selling on the network on our behalf
obviously we're a wholesaler so I think
we've made from the phenomenal progress
in a relatively short period of time in
the terms of an infrastructure build
sounds like it what's been the business
model that's helped create it well I
suppose the unique thing as you said
about sorrow is the fact that we're
building on the electrical network so
that gives us the pathways already there
and to connect into the homes so we work
with our contractors and we build out on
that network and pass homes but as far
as our business model is we're a
wholesaler so we actually just passed
the building and then make that
information available to a number of
retailers and then they contact their
home users and sell it on so the suppose
the fact that we're an open access
non-discriminatory
platform means that we've got lots of
people out there selling on our behalf
obviously so that the business model is
sort of underpinned and by our ability
to build you know relatively quickly use
an electrical network and then have
a number of retailers selling on our
behalf and what are some of the benefits
they're all getting any other retailers
the businesses and and the individual
end-users well I suppose if you look at
our our sort of our customers first
which are really the retailers and we
also obviously end customers but what
the retailers get is access to a
best-in-class system so we don't have
any of the issues that the legacy copper
systems would have so our IT platform is
brand new it's you know fit for purpose
today it hasn't been sort of cobbled
together over over many years from
upgrading this and upgrading that so if
you you know want to we call it Cyril
part if you want to come on to our
network as a retailer you use soil
report it's absolutely designed to be
user-friendly whereas I'd say some of
the incumbents across York's and
interfaces were not necessarily so
user-friendly so the retailer gets a
fantastic experience interfacing with us
and then the network is new it's on a
very robust and I like it built on a
very robust electrical network so the
reliability is very high in terms of the
service service levels that we can give
on it and obviously for the end consumer
then we're building a gigabit network so
they can get a gigabit of connectivity
into their home or into their business I
mean and that's that's the possibility
no I mean what excites me is I really
don't understand what you can do with a
gigabit but that's really the exciting
part is because there's lots of clever
people out there and kids coming through
and businesses and startup and
entrepreneurs that can take that
capacity and that yeah I think and build
fantastic businesses out of it and
obviously then you know at a residential
level you know it's entertainment drives
it but it's really then he help
eLearning working from home all the
stuff that internet connectivity so with
what the fiber-to-the-home council hears
about you know that sort of vision of
the future where fibre is ubiquitous and
everybody's able to benefit from their
you know the opportunity that it brings
more congratulations and what you've
done so far I'm sure we'll hear more
from you in the future thank you very
much Brian appreciate it so a unique all
fiber network spreading right across
Ireland
[Music]
you